[Music]
hey ladies and gentlemen
yeah it's sunday sunday and i'm sleeping
hold on let me shut that door again
yeah pookie keeps coming in here and
like busting the door
she's very hyperactive yeah for some
reason i don't i
you know we were talking about last
night maybe it's because we ran out of
temptations and we haven't gone to the
store again anymore yet and we're giving
her some of the other ones and i think
she's mad about it
because man she's before we turn the
show on she kept jumping up here and
trying to like
fight nothing biting all the cords and
[ __ ] like that i'm like don't make me
spray you with lemon juice because i
will
she keeps running up to me when i'm up
on the bed watching tv gets up on top of
the
the uh nightstand and pulls things off
throws them and i can hear her sliding
something across
you know remotes and stuff and i'll look
like that and she'll freeze going
i'm not moving it and then you look away
i'm just standing here like normally
yeah yeah i told it it's like it's it's
really really funny like when she wants
to get your attention she's like the
the nightstand you know there's like
stuff on it and
you'll see like her little ears poke up
on the far side of the nightstand and
then her little paw comes up and she
grabs so then it starts sliding
yeah she's got hands she uses hands it's
looking ridiculous
i've never seen a can you can't use
hands like that i think she's a monkey
oh shoot that fingers extended and
she'll grab something to start sliding
she wants it to make maximum noise
either that or she'll bang the uh
the blinds against the window she'll be
like
wake up yeah she does that a lot too
she's like this is not acceptable
yeah she's like funny as hell but uh
yeah so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
show last night
i feel like i feel like i felt good
about that show
i mean i feel good about most of our
shows but at least i didn't get
you were getting slashed i wasn't too
sloshed and like i i
covered everything i wanted to cover and
[ __ ] like that
you know uh actually after the show was
over last night we actually had
yet another drink and then we we watched
uh coming to america
yeah i had to catch up on that because
uh t
said yeah next week she reminded me that
next week the new one's coming out yeah
part two is coming out movie uh held up
well over over the decades as anxious
that movie is it still looks good
yeah yeah i hadn't seen it since i was
in my 20s probably had some good
matte shots um back in
back in uh wakanda no it's not wakanda
what was in there it's like
yeah that's [ __ ] hilarious they're
talking the [ __ ] lines of tigers are
running by the windows and [ __ ]
zebras all these [ __ ] animals
i right that a lot of the jokes there
was a lot of kind of over-the-top zany
jokes but i liked that a lot of the gags
were kind of
subtle or they weren't really you know
focused on
i thought that was i'd forgotten about
that what's funny is that i forgot that
it was a rom-com
that is very funny that you forgot that
yeah i just thought i
thought of it as an eddie murphy movie
you know but yeah seen it again i was
like man this is a romantic comedy
you know uh but it was it was pretty
cool i liked it
yeah so now we're all ready to see the
new one when it comes out
yeah which i yeah i think it's next
weekend i think they're adding it
so we'll see how it goes but you can
watch it uh original cast and everything
you can watch on amazon prime for free
well there's a bunch of other like eddie
murphy movies on there too i think
trading places was on there
vampire brooklyn was on there i forgot
that the two guys from trading places
had a damn cameo
and and i had i had forgotten that as
well yeah
so it's all it's in shared universe yeah
dropping their they were bombs they were
on the side of the road looking
[ __ ] what's his name prince what
prince uh
who eddie murphy's here yeah his
character was called i came
i came i just said it every name yeah
akeem
[Laughter]
prince akeem gave him a big wad of cash
and uh they were oh we're back in the
game look look they gotta have enough
money to start an investment start
business again that's pretty good
fourth straight down says joe lewis was
137 years old yeah that's right
all those barbershop really [ __ ]
funny
i forgot how [ __ ] funny that [ __ ] was
yeah
all right so uh even though we're
playing like about seven years
late on this yeah uh but whatever
so true detective i had heard about it
around the periphery uh heard about like
it won all these emmys won a bafta won
like all these awards
so i'd always heard about how brilliant
it was and i just had never got around
to watching it
i don't know i guess because i you know
we don't have hbo
and so i missed out on a lot of stuff
like i haven't seen the wire i haven't
seen anything like that which sucks and
i really should get around to it one of
these days
because you know everybody talks about
it and it's you know and i just missed
out on a lot of cultural
[ __ ] i guess but sophie sent us the
first season of this
and we actually sat there and watched it
took us two nights right i think we
watched like half of
like four of them and then four of them
the next night yeah the blue ray's got
three
discs in it and i think it's uh three
episodes per disc i think well no i
think wait a minute
yeah it was three three and three
wouldn't it well no i think well
hang on yeah well there's only eight
episodes though
in total maybe the second how i had uh
two yeah maybe the second one only has
but i can't remember okay because i'm
pretty
sure we matter yeah the the the blu-ray
set is real nice all the loading screens
and the way it's set up you can even
uh you know ask to see recaps from the
you know i mean from
like a recap from the last episode in
case you forgot something um
real good score the the the design
the graphic design behind the movie on
the loading screens and on the blue
ridge [ __ ] fans oh my god and that
opening sequence
is amazing yeah and and really the
strong point
of this series well the acting is great
matthew mcconaughey and [ __ ] oh
what's his name
damn dude from woody harrelson woody
harrelson man they just knock it out of
the park in this [ __ ] movie
these characters are just perfect for
them and the writing is really good
you know it's about uh two hard-boiled
detectives from uh they were from cid
which is uh like state police
intelligence or
state police investigative body for
louisiana and uh you know having lived
in louisiana and
[ __ ] done some support for [ __ ] at
the state police level
they nailed it this is exactly the way
those guys are
and uh even with all the foibles and the
[ __ ] they're human too
they do stupid [ __ ] casting was great
because all the supporting cast was
recruited from louisiana so
they got the louisiana [ __ ] accents
and the
some of the [ __ ] they just [ __ ]
nailed some of it i mean um
mcconaughey is not from louisiana's from
[ __ ] texas i think
right well he was from texas in the show
too he's lived all over the place
so he's not he's considered to be like
an outsider they think he's [ __ ]
weird because he's too deep
but when you look at him you know just
you just got to see the movie
harrelson's [ __ ] great he's he's just
like a local good old boy
type detective who gets into a [ __ ] ton
of trouble with women he just can't keep
it in his pants
but it's kind of hard to blame him
because the girls were those women were
hot man the ones were coming out
he kept cheating on his wife and getting
busted and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] just a
great series you know
um they're trying to track down this
serial killer
and it's it's kind of us
he's i don't want to spoil too much of
it it's kind of like he's a serial
killer that has a religion
and there must be a group of them and
it's kind of like something out of
mid-summer
or uh you know or uh
maybe like wicker man and uh it's kind
of a
louisiana interpretation of it you know
um
like an old tribal throwback religion
[ __ ] happening out in the woods
sacrificing
women and children and [ __ ] doing weird
stuff with them
and there's some kind of conspiracy
going on it's not just one guy it's a
whole bunch of them
and it goes across their career
different time periods and in the last
half
the second half of the series they've
already
well actually could it's not linear
they're doing a lot of flashbacks and
flash forwards you hard to tell it's
hard to tell exactly
what time frame everything's happening
and then you have to watch their hair
and see how old they are at any time
but um eventually they leave the force
and they start their own private
investigation company
trying to crack that old case that they
never really felt comfortable you know
they didn't think they solved it which
turns out they did but just real good
real good series man it's almost on par
with that
first couple see first couple seasons of
remember um the one about ancient rome
spartacus yeah the first couple seasons
of spartacus how good that was
yeah yeah spartacus that was that was
that was a long time ago a long time so
i want to see that one again
well that was the one where like the
main actor like after the season when he
died or something like really young and
they had to get a different guy
and it never recovered the writing
wasn't as good it just kind of i kind of
feel like that happens like okay so
true detective one i love that this is
an anthology series i haven't seen two
or three
um i feel like the first season this one
that we watched
was the one that got all of the praise
everybody loved season one
season two and three were more mixed um
but i like that they were kind of
self-contained in the sense that it was
a totally different cast totally
different story
[ __ ] like that which in a way kind of
worked to their advantage because they
could get
bigger like a-list actors because you
didn't have to commit to being in a
series
that might for all you know run for
[ __ ] eight nine ten seasons and you'd
be obligated you know what i mean you
couldn't make movies or anything
so he said you know this is gonna be
like eight episodes it's standalone
story i think it only took like three
months to shoot it
um you know so they could get kind of
like bigger actors and i think that uh
matthew mcconaughey uh he was the one
that they mainly wanted
and he actually i think they wanted him
to play the other role they wanted him
to play marty
but he came forward he said no no i want
to play
cole you know i want to play that guy
because he really wanted to get into
that dude's head
the you know what i think makes this
show i mean i
loved every single [ __ ] thing about
this show
every single thing i can't think of or i
can't think of a single thing i did not
like about this show it was just
i love the way they took something
um that was kind of like you know the
buddy cop like two cops and they don't
get along and they're
trying to find like this weird serial
killer with like all these with all this
weird like iconography and stuff
it's like not a super original idea it's
been done a lot of times before
but the way that they did it's like the
[ __ ] character work and everything
because it seemed like the [ __ ] about
the serial killer and all that
was almost kind of like it was i don't
want to say it was background
but it was kind of like not the most
important thing
i mean the most important thing was
their characters like their character
arcs
and kind of the whole like thematic
thrust of the show
there was like so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
going on here and it's like
somebody just mentioned it's like you
really have to watch this like a whole
bunch of times to pick everything up
now one of the things that i did pick up
there's a lot of like religious
metaphors like
especially like a whole jesus thing
going on at the end
um was all of the stuff about the serial
killer
and uh carcosa and the yellow king and
everything
well i recognize that because you know
i'm a horror
nerd so i was like oh um robert w
chambers
wrote a short story collection back in
the late 1800s 1895 something like that
called the king in yellow um and
that's what they're referencing now i
think he was referencing an
earlier story by amber's beers where
they mentioned karkosas as a whole thing
and then h.p lovecraft picked up on the
robert chambers thing
and used that in some of his [ __ ] as
well so this is kind of like a whole
lovecraftian
kind of [ __ ] going on there and then you
have like this whole philosophical [ __ ]
going on too like with the whole thing
about like pessimism
and you know existentialism like the
meaning of life and everything
and like the two of them uh the two of
the
the two of them having their
conversations about like their
completely different world views
no poop what are you jumping up here
uh oh oh oh oh oh no don't step on it
don't step on it yeah don't step on it
just just stay there pull her down just
stay there okay come here little
she's treating me she's gonna fight yeah
she's trying to hey
what'd you do get attention she's trying
to be
uh very hyperactive today yeah she's
very very hyperactive today i'm not
really sure why
but yeah she's just like i just loved
like all the
you know kind of weird here hang on to
her for a second
like all those kind of references it was
just like so
i don't know just and just like the
conversations they have like they're too
um like i said they're too opposing i
guess
the way they looked at life or whatever
and then matthew mcconaughey going
through this whole
thing and almost kind of like having a
conversion or what they would call like
a
damascus moment or something like that
like at the end with all the jesus
iconography and stuff
i mean it's just so [ __ ] great and i
think one of the things that makes this
awesome is that the dude who nowadays
they would call the showrunner
nick pizzalotto he actually first
conceived this
as a novel right and um
after he wrote it he was kind of like
well i think this would work better
uh you know as a tv series just because
of you know
it going back and forth in time and he
just thought it was like you know
the visuals would be really cool so he
uh tried to get you know uh for a tv
series
and eventually there was a bidding war
because i guess it was like a lot of
people wanted it and uh
i think hbo gave him like four or four
and a half million per episode
to do eight episodes and another thing
that's awesome
is that he didn't have a
writing staff because you know how
mostly shows
uh tv series are written by a bunch of
writers you know what i mean they have a
writing room and it's like they're all
in there they come with ideas
bounce them off each other uh nick pitts
did not want to do that
he's basically like well i just don't
think i have a vision for what i want
this show to be
and i don't want a bunch of you know i
don't want a writing staff i just want
this to be like
a novel and i want to do it so it was
just him and the director he didn't have
a staff he just like wrote it by himself
and so i think that that made it a lot
more focused and a lot more
um you know it was much more one
person's vision you could really really
see that
also love the whole aesthetic of it they
shot it on 35 millimeter because he
wanted it to look more like
a film like you know what i mean um i
think originally they were supposed to
shoot it in arkansas
but then because louisiana has all those
kind of tax breaks and [ __ ] like that
for
filming there and also he really liked
the whole
like decadent landscapes and everything
because it was kind of like a reflection
of the
moral [ __ ] of the characters you know
what i mean yeah they captured the
louisiana white trash
dynamic oh yeah in certain areas i mean
that's it that's it right there yeah and
sometimes it's a little uh
you know it's a it's got horror elements
so it's over the top on certain
parts but you know you can tell what's
real and what isn't real
yeah and it's just kind of like i don't
know it was just so [ __ ] great and
everything
the two of them when they like the
conversations they had was great even
when matthew mcconaughey's character was
just like monologuing
it was great everybody everything about
this was just like so compelling like
all the characters were so compelling
you know the mystery was kind of
compelling but even if it wasn't
um you just wanted to watch these
characters and see how [ __ ] was gonna
happen
yeah the main bad guys they uh kind of
stood out
real good acting everybody was great
acting um
the locals that they got in you know
because the accents
it's hard to fake that accent but then
the two i don't know if the two
um um black detectives were from
um louisiana but i bought it that they
that they were
and they just they got the accent the
mannerisms down
it was great because um rusty who's
played by
mcconaughey is [ __ ] doing a
this is supposed to be happening in the
future you know he's no longer a cop
he's
his hair is all long and he's got this
scraggly white trash mustache
and [ __ ] and they're uh asking about you
know his old case and a lot of times
he's bullshitting and lying through the
whole thing and he's just talking and
telling all these stories
just trying to just charming the hell
out of these damn
detectives and they're just sitting
there listening to them you know and
tell this whole story and
they [ __ ] fool you because they're
kind of
shucking and jiving you know letting him
talk you know they're kind of
amos and amos and andy in him until
[ __ ] you know what i mean like to
make him think that they're buying all
this [ __ ] and this goes on for like what
four episodes yeah and then all of a
sudden just
boom they pounce on him and they just
come out as like [ __ ] real competent
detectives like oh you forgot we were
detectives uh this is an interrogation
you know
and uh you bullshitting this you know
[ __ ] we know the book of this and
that they wouldn't show them the [ __ ]
case that they had
he got flustered pissed off and walked
out you know they threatened to
damn um get a search warrant to look at
his
uh his uh what was his story storage
unit and everything and it was just like
that's the first thing first time you
see it from those two supporting
characters
because you're just thinking that that
he's pushing him over
that they're just pushovers nah they
were just waiting to pounce they had
built a whole case up
against him in in their heads and
everything oh you forgot we were [ __ ]
investigators i love that
when they turn the tables on him like
that that was a great scene
i was gonna mention yeah because they
had me believing that they were weak
detectives
yeah dude through that yeah i was gonna
mention too that the director
actually like followed around a bunch of
louisiana
police detectives yeah like hung out
with them for a really long time while
they were working on this show
um but yeah i was just i'm just really
really glad even though like i said i'm
seven years late
that i got around to seeing this because
i didn't realize
that i don't know i don't really know
what my perception was i just remember a
lot of people talking about it i
remember everybody talking about how
amazing it was and i was just kind of
like oh it's probably like a true crime
thing it's like i'll probably get around
to it one of these days and i just never
did because you know i love that kind of
[ __ ]
but um i didn't realize like how [ __ ]
layered it would be how much it had kind
of taken
you know the tropes of true crime tv
shows like buddy cop kind of stuff
and just used it to sort of like explore
all these
like kind of deep philosophical
themes and then it obvious you know it
almost kind of had like a little bit
of a lovecrafty type of [ __ ] going on
yeah and like i said just the whole
aesthetics of it amazing that opening
sequence
is just like gorgeous i mean so like i
said i'm a graphic designer so it's like
all that kind of stuff just
just makes me go squee you know what i
mean because that stuff is so beautiful
and it's like i love um and i think it's
that won a bunch of awards too like the
opening sequence
i loved like the opening song which uh
was by the handsome family
and uh they like some good [ __ ] music
in there i thought the grinder man was
in there
over the closing credits i think i heard
some captain beefheart in there
um but yeah that was like a bunch of
cool [ __ ] they said that
they didn't really want to use they
figured like once they had them once
they moved the
production to louisiana because like i
said originally they were intending to
do it in arkansas
um they said well we didn't really want
to do
you know a score that was kind of like
what you would expect from louisiana
like you know swamp blues or something
like that
um we wanted to do something a little
bit different so they used kind of like
a lot of different kinds of
music i think there was some wu-tang
clan in there at some point um
but yeah so i it just had it had such a
great like aesthetic
thing like all its own it was like so
cinematic and it was it reminded me a
little bit of
seven in a way but a lot better you know
what i mean like i love seven
but it definitely had that same kind of
quality about it
you know what i mean where it was just
kind of exploring these larger themes of
like light dark good evil
that type of stuff um you know all
nietzsche and
kind of stuff and all that you know yeah
his partner was to have a shut up people
like people around here don't talk that
way
that's true mississippi louisiana and
alabama they they
do not like any even parts of florida
they don't like any of that
uh intellectual voters
that's just considered false that's fake
even though i have to say
i mean i know that matthew mcconaughey
was
kind of portrayed as like a very very
pessimistic a very damaged character
because you know like i said his
daughter had died and he just
had kind of come to a point in his life
where he just thought that was you know
nothing had any meaning
um you know and he was just like
completely you know
a materialist and a pessimist and
everything but i have to say that i
really
his character really kind of resonated
with me because a lot of stuff that he
said
was the same kind of way that i think
you know what i mean not i'm not that
depressed or anything or that nihilistic
but a lot of [ __ ] he said like really
resonated and so i so i really really
liked that character and it was just
very very funny to me
that him and woody harrelson would be
like in the car and like matthew
mcconaughey would be like talking about
his thing and like
what he would just be like looking at
him like shut the [ __ ] up
just i love that dynamic if anybody
actually knows
what that structure was at the end of
the series you can drop
it in the comment section uh at the very
end when he finds the uh
the with yellow king isn't that what is
that the name that he went by
yellow yeah once they find him
he runs down into some kind of a
brickwork
a brick construction it was semi-buried
it looked like
a stables but it was kind of buried and
i've never seen
anything like that in louisiana or in
mississippi
i don't know if that was an old 1800s
uh waterworks or what but i didn't know
if that was maybe the
old-fashioned water department it was it
was really there it wasn't
uh a set yeah as far as i know they shot
the whole thing in louisiana so it must
have been some
sites that they found yeah i don't know
what it was it looked kind of like a
horse stable in a way
but it was buried and but it was open at
the top but it was
down in there thank you mango thank you
just kicked cthulu in the nards
yeah like sheila ann was a
quote from the show i start drinking at
noon you don't get to interfere with
that
see i was like i feel you man i feel you
i don't i don't usually start drinking
that early but you know
grandpa's hammer says it was a state
park an old military battery okay
okay yeah we were wondering about it we
were watching cause i was like wow
that's a great
location i wonder where that is because
you know you lived in louisiana for a
while yeah i didn't see anything like
that
there yeah just some buried military
facility i guess
it's definitely 1800s yeah by looking at
the bricks and just the architecture
they look cool this kind of semi-buried
head
damn dome dome ceiling in one spot with
a hole in the top of it
i don't know you know
it's crazy to me how even though i guess
i mean i'm assuming because they were
initially going to shoot it in arkansas
that that's what the original script had
so it's amazing to me that
once they decided to shoot it in
louisiana
louisiana became a character of its own
you know what i mean it was just kind of
like it it was so louisiana
that just like seeped into every single
thing yeah
and i and i just love like i said i love
the way they
use the environment like you know the
outside shots and [ __ ] like that to kind
of reflect
what everybody was going through like
everyone's feelings it's even worse than
here
in terms of like uh moss and
[ __ ] mildew and mold and heat
and humidity it's it's uh it's pretty
bad
you know yeah it gets hot hot and humid
and they have real swamps there with the
damn knees sticking up
out of the trees and uh it's just
stinks in certain areas you know at
certain times of the year
because just [ __ ] swamps they don't
smell good at all
you know so it's like dagobah yeah
hot real hot and humid yeah
grandfather's hammer says fort macomb
state historic park okay fort mccomb
[ __ ] my coma
yeah fort mccall all right
it looked cool that's where the serial
killer was hiding he had it all decked
out
little twigs and [ __ ] i like too that
even though this was it's a standalone
like the eight episodes are standing
alone like i said there's three seasons
but the other two are like completely
different stories and completely
different cast
so i like i think
when this first came out i feel like a
lot of people
complained not complained but they were
kind of like oh they were expecting
there to be like some twist ending or
they were expecting
some of this that and the other but i
kind of like the way
this has a lot of like little bit
fantastical elements a little bit
because um
you know rust has
you know he he says that because of all
the drug use because he you know i've
been undercover and he'd been using all
the drugs for like really
like four years trails and [ __ ] and so
he's so he can see things like and he
has these weird visions and [ __ ]
so there's like a little bit of that in
there but i really kind of like the way
they kept everything other than that
really really grounded and they kind of
left everything they didn't leave
everything hanging they did
wrap everything up but i really like the
way they wrapped everything up just like
in a
in a realistic way like not it didn't
end up like some of these kind of
crime true crime or cop kind of movies
end up it's like oh we caught the bad
guy and everything's
good now um it's like it kind of ends
like that but
they're cheering they didn't catch
everybody they're still that's just the
way it is
and that's just kind of the way it is
and i really really like
that they kind of i don't know like i
really like the way they balanced
the pessimism i thought it was a good
conflict what'd you yeah you think
danny's i thought it was a real
accurate cop flick and they did have
i'm pretty sure that that was apparent
some paranormal events had happened in
it
i think you know he was kind of in touch
with his uh
kind of [ __ ] um what do you call it
collective unconscious his inner cut you
know his
he kind of had uh he had a little bit of
psychic ability
when he went down into that that fort
where uh the yellow king was a serial
killer
for a second he looked up and he saw a
damn
vortex in space kind of whirling around
in there like a doorway into another
dimension you saw it for a few
for just a few seconds they show it to
you they faded away because you got hit
yes i think it was there maybe i mean
this really did have a little bit of a
cosmic horror
yeah type of sprinkling on top which i
do which i really dug i like that
you have to you have to you have to
think about this
this was a group of powerful people that
had been doing this
these human sacrifices on children for a
long period of time
you know at least a hundred years right
and that basically what they were saying
well yeah because it was like
generational was it not yeah
so they weren't doing it for nothing
they must have been getting something
out of it yeah and they moved up
in society into places of power and
wealth
supposedly and not really proven but it
probably did
they were doing it for a long period of
time for a reason that vortex had
something to do with it
yeah maybe they really haven't kind of
summoned something something yeah some
elder god type of [ __ ]
some kind of a portal to another
dimension you know into
into the spirit world that and i liked
how they didn't give you any details
about what it was
well because he went off on you yeah i
mean well you know
rust goes off a couple times he talks
about like m brain theory and like some
kind of you know
stuff that was kind of current at the
time of physics and when he would get a
lead
he would go this is it and when he
showed up when he found that house he
goes this is the place this is it
yeah he had like he had an inner voice
yeah so no he was
he was a you would call him a psychic i
don't think that's a good
word i think that's a woo type of word
yeah it's just
some people can hear an inner voice
that tells them this way that way yes no
that kind of yeah he just had
images right he was intuitive
right well and that's why he was kind of
one of the best ones with and they said
that like they established it
in the first you know when they first
find the body of dora lange
um and he had all these kind of feelings
about it
well hi polk what'd you do with it
she's like i'm gonna go over here you
guys are not paying attention to me
but yeah so you're saying season three
louie is saying seasons
season three is even better really but
to check it out
yeah i mean it's i looked at the i
looked at the videos he agrees
i looked at the thing and it seemed like
two and three got a lot more mixed
reviews than one did i mean one's pretty
much like universally
loved and two and three were kind of
like ah some people liked it some people
hated it
um you know i i don't think i think what
ended up happening was that i think they
had
you know the first season was just nick
pizzalotto
and you know he was the sole writer on
it so it was just like basically his
vision like him in the director
i think they got more writers later um
he was the writer on all of them as far
as i can determine but i think they did
have
he did have more of like a writing staff
maybe on the later ones and i think
people
don't like that as much somebody said
that the ending sucked i don't think it
did though
hey will you stop it she's gonna she's
gonna knock that over uh-oh
pokey stop being bad oh my goodness
she's being such a brat today
i thought the ending was good because it
didn't uh it didn't answer all the
questions
which in reality that's you wouldn't
have all the questions answered
and it was kind of like wrapped up both
of their character arcs you know what i
mean it kind of
i i think there was a little bit of
particularly in
maybe the uh atheist community because
they were kind of like oh
you know we really liked rust's
character that he was like this big
pessimistic
like you know materialist atheist you
don't see a lot of that
um you know what you don't see a lot of
that like portrayed
hey you're being bad get down get down
there you go um and so they kind of
thought the end where it's
almost seemed like like he was kind of
like oh you know i believe in god now or
i believe in an afterlife now or
something like that which
you know that's kind of like a you know
glib way of putting it
but i think a lot of people didn't
really like that but i don't i don't
know i don't know if that's entirely
i i think it was more a sense of like he
came to a place where he could hope
again
you know what i'm saying they're
defending season two also
i mean well yeah it's like i'll
definitely i definitely want to see
season two in season three now
yeah um but yeah just this whole
like i said this first season i just
loved everything about it
and it's just i can see why everybody
was would you stop it
this ended up like oh it froze okay it
froze um
it didn't freeze here oh okay well maybe
we should like
yeah it's been um yeah we've been going
for a while yeah maybe we should just
stop it just stop it and wrap it up
all right yeah we will uh be back
tomorrow so thanks everybody for
dropping by we're losing the stream
so uh yeah we'll see you guys tomorrow
bye